but uh we so let's let's do this let's
what's going to happen what's going to
happen in
uh november check out the story from fox
news democrats might not
accept election results if trump wins
street battles
could ensue atlantic writer they're not
even hiding it anymore trump 2020 deputy
communications director said
the democrats in my opinion will not
accept the results the republicans in my
opinion will not accept the results it
doesn't matter whose side you're on both
sides are not going to accept the
results would you would you both agree
yes you think so sorry i get i hope they
do
but you i mean it's with mail and voting
you really i don't no one has to accept
anything so all the mail and votes are
counted
i would like you to read this headline
for me uh ian well this says
pennsylvania
mail ballots can't be discarded over
signature
what does that mean well would you like
to read the can you read the first
paragraph sure can
let me let me put on my glasses and i
can do it from here yeah i'm like not
wearing your glasses so
hello uh yeah from harrisburg
pennsylvania the ap
reports with concerns rising in
pennsylvania that tens of thousands of
mail and ballots will be discarded in
the presidential election over
technicalities
officials in the presidential
battleground told counties they aren't
allowed to reject the ballot solely
because an election official believes a
signature doesn't match the one in the
voters file
whoa so wrong signature doesn't matter
yep who's gonna accept the results of
this election no one should there's
gonna be a ballot
and it's gonna be from john doe and it's
gonna be like this beautiful cursive
signature and they're going to look at
the file it's going to be in this
the file is going to be like squiggly
left-handed garbage and they're going to
be like looks good to me
you know signatures are a weird form of
security anyway i agree
because anyone could forge my signature
so what do you do fingerprint i don't
something like that yeah yeah you dip
your finger in that weird ink and then
onto the paper maybe how do you do
fingerprint announcements how do you how
do you acknowledge that it's your
fingerprint from a distance
dna everyone has to take a drop of blood
a drop of blood no wash slice
maybe fingerprint maybe fingerprint
along with a signature dude dude dude no
bro what are you some kind of republican
i hope not but listen listen the
democrats are saying get rid of voter id
the democrats are saying get rid of
voter signature verification
what how else do you verify it they
don't want it that is weird you're
sitting here talking about more security
like some kind of republican
look at this hippie guy this hippie
looking guy
long hair abraham lincoln was a
republican there you go
he was correct yeah they hated that he
started that party i'd be at that party
and then they killed him for it well
john wilkes booth did
yeah he was famous you know yeah he was
like a real famous actor that's crazy
could you imagine if like
you know like alec baldwin uh yes i can
oh my breaks into the oval office
but he's dressed like trump like when
that costs him he's like i gotta put an
end to this
that's kind of that's kind of like what
that was wasn't it he was like a really
famous actor he was a famous stage actor
and that's how we had access i guess so
look at this i got more stories man
male ballots can't be discarded over
signature it's not just that they're
saying
it's good to go they're saying that
people need a chance to fix it
but come on man if you if like to quote
joe biden come on dude you said it just
like
come on man look at this way let's say
you look at a signature
and there's like someone counting
ballots and they look at the signature
from the ballot and they look at the
signature on file
and it is clearly not the same
handwriting
they should be able to throw the trash
but they don't have to now they can't
they can't they can't and so the idea is
you can go back to the person and ask
them to fix it
okay if somebody signs you know and then
you look at it it's kind of the same but
you can't tell
that makes sense to be like okay this
this looks different but we're gonna
we're gonna send it back to the person
to fix that's gonna delay the election
by what
several weeks to months but like when i
i fill out forms i was just filling out
a form
recently for like my license and on my
signature i just did it a little wrong
it didn't look like my normal signature
but they're gonna accept it right so
what happens when the signature is
wildly different and now they can't
reject it
well that's that's screwed up yeah
mm-hmm they just have to
accept it well i guess they'll send it
back to the person and then
okay so it's going to be another four
weeks before we and then we get what's
we get pelosi
president interim president pelosi wow
because someone will send it back and
it'll be the wrong signature again and
then
and then what's she gonna do fire
trump's people or whatever she should
have pelosi as president oh my god what
would happen
if she if if if the house election goes
the way it's supposed to and the
presidency gets jammed up
yes she becomes president on january
20th well maybe that's the president
america needs right now
no craziness can all see how crazy
things are yeah
but hold on but wait there's more just
don't you stop there
uh actually this is the wrong story but
it's interesting nonetheless i never
considered voting for trump in 2016 i
may be forced to vote from this year
more than 20 000 mail ballots were
tossed out in pennsylvania's 2020
primaries
of pennsylvania that's half of president
trump's margin of 40 000 votes in the
state in 2016.
what is this story democrats are more
likely than republicans to mail in
ballots early according to a poll
just feels like they're prepping us for
all of this insanity
they're telling us well the democrats
are going to send in more ballots that
way
that's why it makes sense that if trump
wins he didn't really win
we'll find boxes yeah we'll go look for
boxes until we find enough votes
fine and if the signatures don't match
it doesn't matter they're good i mean we
need internet voting this is the year
that's going to show we have to have
online secure voting
but how do you secure online voting well
like we were saying blockchain's a
little risky because they can do
coordinated attacks yeah some sort of
decentralized service that maybe it's
not a blockchain but like a dat
protocol or something someone could
easily break into that dude the problem
with with with cyber security
is that you got what what about 7.2
billion people yeah something like that
how many how many of these individuals
it's a distributed computer and they're
all trying to crack the code to break
into our secure voting system
somebody's gonna find it but this is
also horribly in
insecure yes so it's like the lesser of
two evils well hold on
it it's it's it's been bad for a lot of
reasons but we can secure it
you know we need we need to secure our
voting uh voting machines they need to
be
checked better because they're easily
hacked and we need to
i don't know have voter uh signature
verification and id cards so right now
you go to a polling place you put it
into a computer
and then that data is transmitted to a
server somewhere no i think it was on a
hard disk
so there's still a lot of heart but it's
still data someone could tamper with
easily very easily and so the way i see
it is we're going from a 30 percent
quality to a 38
equality or something if you do
internet-based voting one dude in russia
is going to be like
here we go and hillary clinton's
president done i would imagine if you
had like a blockchain or something that
you could follow the trail of changes so
if someone tried to tamper with it you
would see it
they changed the whole chain man you
might be i'm just not an expert but
i can't imagine there's anything other
than that that would be better than this
when you have
physical ballots there are challenges
because this is why
one of the reasons the electoral college
is so important that it's often
overlooked
uh it's a really great argument too that
people don't bring up
if all that matters is new york la and
chicago
for because of the popular vote or
california then it's really easy for one
person to forge a ton of votes in one
area to make it seem like they all came
from california because there's more
people there
and that makes sense with the electoral
college they'd have to forge votes in
every single state in different counties
so that the state
wins there for their candidate get it
security advantage yeah so with the
national popular vote you need to only
rig one election
with electoral college vote you need to
rig 50 elections
it makes it much much more difficult to
steal yeah and people
again people don't talk about it it's
one of the most important reasons why we
have the
college what if you had like an online
local election thing where there was a
bunch of local accounts and then they
were all
like calibrated or collated
the speed at which you can tran you can
alter and transmit
data over the internet is is is rapid it
would be like the difference between
getting a physical newspaper printed and
sent to your house and pulling up the
website
the moment the person writes the story
it's right there in front of you with
the paper
they write the story then they print it
on the page and then
then they set it to this you know that
they they send the uh the design to the
system
they print out all the papers put them
on trucks deliver them to various you
know distributors or houses or whatever
finally get your paper it took a day to
do and a lot of work a lot of people
involved
it's very difficult to get you a
physical piece of paper it's very easy
for them to press
enter and send you a a story and they
have security on their website
they do and someone could easily hack
their
accounts and they've done it we recently
saw high profile twitter users get
hacked
and twitter's got security imagine if
they had to go to that person's house
all of these celebrities and print out
statements from them
and give them out well first it would
take six months
and that's a big problem because we
don't have six months from november 4th
to figure out who the president is right
maybe that's their goal their goal is
kamikaze just if if
it can't be them then no president at
all fire everything
yeah more than that just no no president
we're just
not gonna have one just gonna make it
draw it out as long as we can't tell
nancy pelosi gets into office
yeah um it could be chuck grassley if
she doesn't get reelected i don't know
or if the republicans win the house so
so this so a lot of people keep saying
president pelosi but
it's possible that the house flips
republican and then you get a republican
speaker and he be in there
an unelected official nobody i don't
think anybody really wants
most people probably don't want an
unelected official to become it would be
an interim president
emergency and and then but they would
stay as the president until
the resolution yeah if it was a
republican though the republican would
probably clear it up
and favor trump and pelosi will probably
favor biden i don't know what they can
do as interim president though to
actually affect what's going on the
election probably a lot
there's gonna be tons of lawsuits we're
not gonna know who won and
in the meantime there's like postal
postal office employees throwing out
bags of d of mail like isn't it that's
been happening i know
these are contractors though so we have
contractors handling our mail
yes that's like our vote that's even
worse private companies are handling our
our presidential votes i have great
confidence in this i don't i don't know
how that works
but there's no chain of custody at the
post office
why am i going to give them i'm not
going to give them my vote are you nuts
but so many people
are it's terrifying all the democrats
are it's it's really weird
it makes sense because the post office
union endorsed biden
oh what's even worse could you imagine
that's what i tell people like imagine
you're a biden voter and
and a guy shows up to your house with
the maga head on saying i'll take your
vote for you
give me your give me your i'll take care
of you i'm gonna get out of here i don't
know i'm not gonna give it i'm gonna
give you my vote begging the universe
for
online voting yeah but that's that's
probably less secure man
it's too late i don't know if it's less
secure equally
but it's fast it's hard i i don't know
it is fast but it's easily exploited by
by you know uh people in other countries
but we can like get our driver's license
online
hey bucko you can get some water at my
house he can't
he can't get any water out of that thing
see if you can good luck so you do a lot
of things online
that are like high security stuff i can
get a credit card online
you know my my personal information
why not voting it doesn't even seem like
that big of a deal because
it can be exploited very easily all
these other systems can be as well china
hacked a whole bunch of like social
security numbers or something so now
they have like everyone's personal
information it's a big deal
oh great yeah so uh look man
i like the idea but i just i just don't
see it not right now at least one step
at a time
because cyber defense is very difficult
cyber offense is extremely easy because
you you can't you can't physically see
where the holes are and where the water
you know the leak is coming from
so people find a way in and you might
not they don't they'll cover their
tracks you'll never know how to
you might not even know they breached
the system you might like even now
i bet i i have very little faith in our
election our elections
the only reason i'm willing to vote this
time is because trump winning in the
first place
proves that voting actually had an
impact because they're freaking out
they're like oh no what happened so i'm
like okay i guess voting matters
but now i think they're cheating i mean
look at this stuff with mail-in voting
dude it is it is beyond
insane uh will chamberlain is a great
tweet he said in-person voting is high
integrity
absentee voting is high integrity
because you request the ballot and they
know who's getting it
universal mailing voting is low
integrity
and if you are trying to reduce the
integrity of our elections we can only
assume it's because you intend to cheat
yeah why would they it's it's because
it's because kovid joe biden just voted
in person
okay that's just right joven voted in
person burks and fauci both said we
could vote in person
there's no reason to have universal mail
in voting by the way you were right he
couldn't get the water
he tried though he was too low he was
good he's trying he's got a couple over
here
bucko's been he's been doing catnip so
he's tripping he's tripping a little bit
oh man i need water thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you